okay we had to restart the damn router i
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
they did actually say that because you
know how we had to get um we ended up
getting the
internet or the wi-fi through the hoa
yeah and they sent me a message that
they were doing
maintenance on it but
i was like wait that i'm pretty sure it
was like the middle of the night though
no no no i don't even know if it was
tonight but i'm pretty sure it was like
two or three in the morning i didn't
think it was like something it was weird
just everything fell
everything just crashed yeah like that
was that it has happened before we did
restart the router but i mean
considering what we had before this is
like not too bad but it does kind of
stress me out that it like does that
kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] all the time
but uh before we came back on we were
talking about pookie's new thing i don't
know if i said this on the show before
she has decided that she's really really
into my hair brush so like whenever i'm
over there in the dressing room brushing
my hair
she jumps up on the sink and starts
yelling and jumps up on my chest and
starts reaching for the brush like brush
pookie's hair brush
like and she won't like let me brush my
hair she gets mad if i try to brush my
she's like no brush my hair and she's
like grabbing at it like that
it's like [ __ ] funny and like i said
i tried to do it a little bit but
if you
do it like she'll stand there for like
an hour
like wanting you to brush your hair and
if you stop she gets really mad and
starts yelling so yeah
uh let's see danny rolling ghost face i
heard a rumor that dr kellogg was giving
out free lobotomy ice picks in his
cereals his prizes
uh that was one thing that he wasn't
that he didn't advocate that i know of
uh was lobotomies yeah but uh he was
into like some other [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
so you know
um
zach said i'm curious to know what tom
was saying about violence on tv
yeah because it must have dropped i'm
not really sure like when it stopped
when it stopped what i was saying
is that um
television was
kind of caught in the middle of a bunch
of different factions that were fighting
each other over the power of the
television back then
television was one of the main new
mediums you know it was like the social
media of the day
so
each region kind of had its own moral
standards of you know what they were
worried about
the south didn't want any nudity on it
oh that's really the only thing they
cared about they didn't care about
violence
other places maybe didn't want violence
on it but they didn't care about nudity
so
they would try to get around it they
wouldn't show any nudity
but they would show violence
but they would do weird [ __ ] like
guys would be shooting each other but
you never saw any blood yeah or if you
did see blood it was black
or if it was although it might have been
just because they couldn't afford the
squib
[Laughter]
there's like just fall down it'll look
like something you've got red
if it looked like blood then
they could get trouble so a lot and they
just shot it in a weird way especially
on especially was made for television
movie
they shot it to where you would never
see any bullet holes appearing anybody
so uh you might see some fist fights
that's about it which is hilarious
because you know jump ahead a couple
decades and then like they started
showing like the walking dead where they
just showed people's faces getting
chewed off like on just regular ass tv
well that was cable though
it was very different
yeah but even on cable back in the 80s
if you had advertisers the only way you
could get away with
showing anything and everything
uh on tv was if you had a pay channel
like hbo or something even if you had
cable that was still advertisers and
advertisers would make you cut out
nudity and swearing
and egregious violence but if you go
back and look a lot of that was just the
main networks abc nbc cbs those are the
ones that they were really [ __ ]
shocking
um they just
it was a dumb time you know [ __ ] it
was dumb and the thing is this is a
television it was
television was not like uh the moral
compass of the nation
just because you saw that [ __ ] on
television i didn't mean that that
wasn't the the mental framework people
were in at that time
i ignored most of that [ __ ] during those
days
it was real second and third rate
television was by the time the by the
time the late 80s had rolled around the
ship was terrible
you weren't watching that you were
renting vhs movies
from blockbuster
actually but you were doing that by the
mid by the mid 80s really in 86 87 i
didn't watch tv i mean we didn't have
blockbuster we had movie gallery which
was like the the scuzzier version that
had the porn in the back and we have
pretty much exclusively watching [ __ ]
we didn't have blockbuster until the 90s
yeah at least where i grew up and i
don't remember there being any problems
renting that [ __ ] r-rated movies
yeah i mean i saw
per al most of them
yeah i mean it was my parents card so
maybe that's why they're like whatever
cause it's good yeah
only people that seem to care about
movie theaters you get around that
yeah even the movie theaters didn't
really give that much of a [ __ ] as long
as you had like your old like an older
sibling or you could just sneak in
honestly
it was easier
to do that just get
you just would get like a pg movie that
was near the time where you wanted to
see the other one you'd go in and you
just switch theaters because especially
in the matinee they would never there
was always uh vacancies they weren't
they didn't have people in there [ __ ]
hey you used to be in this movie they
weren't doing that
well yeah how would they know they
wouldn't you know they don't they're not
like going around checking your ticket
or nothing nope me and my little brother
went to like the all-night uh nightmare
on elm street
thing like i think when the third or
fourth one came out or the fifth one i
don't remember what it was but whenever
like one of the fourth or fifth one came
out they did like a whole night of like
all the old ones and then like leading
up to the new one
and we were both underage i think
but i think my mom just went up there
and bought him tickets and were like
they're fine
i said it's okay
and then she went home
so they let us in they didn't care in
the 80s
grandpa's going to test he we went to
high school together for a couple years
i went to high school in brazil and and
in michigan
and they were both wild in the 80s
uh sex was off the chain
and it had been that way going back to
the 60s and the 70s
it was never really prudish
uh based on the statistics i'm hearing
now
teenagers right now are having much less
sex than we used to have
it was wild
but it depends i guess depending on who
you were some people never got laid but
delayable people were [ __ ] like crazy
well the thing about it is that
i always kind of think that whenever you
think oh this time was prudish or
anything like that i don't think there
was such a time no um it was only just
how things were portrayed in the popular
media at the time that changes i don't
think it's
necessarily the way people behave and we
had all that much we had gay kids and
lesbian kids we knew who they were and
nobody was bothering them
uh caitlin higgins says do you think
there's any kind of correlation between
the suppression of sex and the perpetual
nature of war and violence there well
you know there might be because i do
kind of feel like there's a particular
i mean and this is maybe on the micro
individual level but there is a
particular type of you know serial
killer or type of uh person that
perpetrates that kind of violence that
um
they had they have a lot of like sex
hang-ups so i think in some types of
personalities it kind of like warps and
comes out like in a weird
uh way like it kind of goes around and
becomes violence
that that can't happen i don't think it
happens across the board
because i think it depends on the type
of personality that you're talking about
but
yeah i i could see that that could
happen
um let's see
no need for me to said it just went
underground like tom said it was
regional trailer park trailer park was
easy pickings
what went underground what'd you talk
about um i don't know except
he was talking about weed earlier oh
um because he was asking if florida was
wheat front i kind of feel like
everywhere is weed friendly now even if
it's not technically illegal like
technically legal yeah i mean you know
nobody i don't even know i don't even
know if it's technically legal here it
doesn't really seem to matter because
everybody just does it anyway and like
nobody says anything about it so
um
danny rowling says i heard that this
facility was hard up on the budget
cutbacks that they would reuse the
yogurt enemas that's the next morning's
breakfast for the patients
just kidding
thank you aaron driving to the mountains
entertain me
i love the show all right just don't
make a hard right or a left and go off
the side of that damn mountain oh my
goodness oh what'd you do pookie threw
the mouse to me you throwing it okay she
wants to play fetch i guess
yeah pick up a toy and throw it with one
hand i mean they did have uh some budget
issues i guess when the great depression
came along
i wouldn't put it past him to reuse the
yogurt enema machines dr uh john kellogg
did invent a sort of like enema machine
that would like shoot all kinds of stuff
up your butt
so yeah
if you were interested i actually did
i remember when this how this
conversation started about the kellogg's
place we did explain what what this
place was right well no because we
hadn't even got to that yeah
honestly let's get to this before
because i think it like [ __ ] crashed
it crashed at 25 minutes
[Laughter]
okay i mean you know
yo i can understand i like i understand
where he was coming from with that but
when you say it when you say yogurt
enemas i mean everybody's like no thanks
i don't want one of those that just like
reminded me of those like crazy people
that were on my strange addiction that
were like shooting coffee up their butts
like
several times a day
um
all right so let's talk about
dr kellogg
and the battle creek sanitarium and like
i said there's all kind of different uh
little tendrils to this kind of story uh
somebody asked earlier if i was gonna
bring up the uh oh pookies out of treats
she's upset you might have to go back in
there and get some because i'm i usually
have a box in here but i'm out she's
like what the [ __ ] is this this is
[ __ ] right here
and she's just like sitting there
waiting by the plate okay i'm gonna wait
but yeah so this goes off into all kind
of different directions like health and
hygiene it goes off into like [ __ ]
medical quackery
religion
all kind of fun stuff so yeah this is
actually kind of like a fun topic sort
of
uh so yeah
now
the battle creek sanitarium and i think
that dr kellogg please uh please correct
me if i'm wrong i'm pretty sure that he
was the one that coined that word
sanitarium because he wanted it to sound
like
a hospital like you know you'll come
here to get healthy but he also wanted
it to be like
sanitation like it's clean you know what
i mean so it's kind of like
you're getting better and it's like
really standard it's sanitized for your
pleasure i don't know
uh so in the early 20th century this was
actually the most popular medical spa in
the u.s and a lot of like famous people
uh went there including like you know
presidents and other uh celebrities of
the day ricardo montebron went there did
he really no made that [ __ ] i was gonna
say that was a little that was a little
before his time yeah this was like late
19th century early 20th century it was
still around like in the depression and
stuff but
uh
i think that uh that dr kellogg died in
the 40s i want to say i think he died in
1943 or he stopped running the place in
1943 something like that
so uh so yeah
dr john kellogg now he was again we
talked about this in the first part of
the show before our internet crapped the
bed
but
but he was uh kind of portrayed in
popular media i think because of rhode
welleville like the book which they made
into a movie with anthony hopkins they
kind of portray him as a little bit of a
quack which
he kind of was but
not necessarily like he did actually
have some good ideas and he actually was
kind of like ahead of his time in some
areas but then he had some kind of like
[ __ ] up ideas too and he was actually
a real medical doctor whatever that
meant at that time so it wasn't like he
was just faking it and most medical
doctors were quacks
well yeah i'm not saying that i'm just
saying that he wasn't like just making
it up like i didn't even go to medical
school i just like wrote my [ __ ] on the
back of like a receipt or something and
it's like yeah look i have a medical
degree it wasn't like that
so uh so he was born in tyrone michigan
i'm not entirely sure where that is in
1852.
now
his dad uh was really into all these
kind of like christian revivalist type
of movements and he kind of like jumped
around from place to place
uh he got the congregationalist church
got the baptist
finally he settles on seventh-day
adventists now if you don't know what
seventh-day adventists are
they're a religious sect that came about
in the wake of the millerites
if you don't know who the millerites are
they were the ones that were kind of
like oh jesus coming for real yeah uh
and particularly in 1844 they had
william miller who was like the head of
it and he's like jesus is coming in 1844
for real you guys so a lot of his
followers sold all their [ __ ] and you
know they had this a whole bunch of
people i can't remember how many people
it was but it was quite a few and they
went to like the top of this hill or
this mountain or whatever like to wait
for jesus to come yeah spoiler alert
jesus didn't come and uh to this day
they still call that the great
disappointment which i think is very
very funny we calculated it though for
for the year following and got another
year out of it well you know that's what
you got to do man you just got to like
you got to keep the grift going yeah
somehow yeah i think i mentioned it on
another on another show
my dad
has
a millerite book it's in his possession
it's probably worth a lot of money it's
a hardcover book it's called
i believe it's miller right you guys can
[ __ ] google it's called rightly
dividing the word
it's [ __ ] dividing or dividing
dividing
i think it's dividing if i remember
correctly
it might be divining but i think it's
dividing
and it's
they're trying to um
calculate when jesus goes back according
to [ __ ] what what's written in in
revelations
and also i think it was the book of
daniel was it daniel was that the one
where the with the big statue with the i
think that was daniel
with the big statue
with the feet of clay and the bronze you
know the bronze breastplate and
everything
um prophecy i think it was daniel
i think boy has been a long time now
anyway he's got that book and i think
it's the first edition which would have
made it made it
what 1860s 1870s
well i don't know the miller rights the
great disappointment happened in 1844
1944 okay so it was even before that
so it might not be a first edition but
it's it is a hardcover it looks old
i would say late 1800s probably yeah
by the look of the book he's got that
book it's a trip
so after that whole thing when jesus
didn't show up the bomb
uh the millerites sort of i don't know
if i'd call it splintered but they did
kind of like go into this other thing
like seventh-day adventists which
is essentially like um
a protestant christian denomination uh
it has a lot of a little more
fundamentalist sort of beliefs
um the only thing kind of that makes
them different they're very very focused
on jesus's return hence adventist
because that's his advent
also um they're not real down with the
whole sunday being the day of worship
kind of thing they go more toward like
the hebrew thing which is the saturday
because they they consider saturday the
seventh day uh so they so there's that
what i got it it's rightly dividing the
word clarence larkin it was the first
edition i'm talking about but it's it's
1920. so it's not the miller rights okay
but it looks cool
i see the pictures of it
kind of like a miller right book
yeah yeah but like i said the miller
rights kind of became i mean i think
they did there were millerites still but
i think it mostly went into the
seventh-day adventist because they they
pretty much believe the same thing they
did actually believe jesus was coming
back but i think they were smart enough
maybe to like not put an exact date on
it just so they wouldn't look like
chumps when it uh when it didn't happen
uh but yeah so the seventh-day adventist
church was actually formally established
in 1865
uh so yeah they have the same kind of
things though it's like you know this
the the bible is inerrant uh you know
what i mean everything in it is uh
correct and uh they also have the whole
trinity thing
but one thing
that the seventh day adventists uh are
big into which feeds right into the dr
john kellogg thing
is that they're super into like your
body being a temple
and so they're very very strict with
what they eat
uh you know they observe kosher food
laws they're real into
vegetarianism they don't make you be a
vegetarian but they encourage it
um they're very like into holistic type
of health they don't like uh alcohol or
smoking
or caffeine even really
and they're real into kind of sexual
abstinence or only
uh having sex when it's like necessary
for procreation so they're really kind
of like
a little bit fundamentalist in that uh
regard all right let me clarify it was
the book of daniel i was talking about
nebuchadnezzar's dream it's also known
as the apocalypse of daniel
that's all that christian
apocalypse stuff my creepy phone's
ringing again yeah
i swear to god i've turned the volume
down on the ringer every day and yet it
still it keeps turning itself back up
so i don't really know why that is
so yeah so we got your seventh day
adventist so uh dr john kellogg when he
was a kid uh grew up in this church
essentially because his dad uh was a
part of it and actually his dad uh
kellogg senior
was
a really big advocate and was actually
just one of four
guys who were in uh who were in the
group
and they gave uh he gave a bunch of
money
to
um these kind of like high up seventh
day adventist ellen white and her
husband james springer white
and he
talked them into moving to battle creek
michigan they had a publishing business
and he's like come to battle creek
michigan and open your publishing
business here
so that's what they did so they moved
there in 1855 and then the kellogg
family
moved to battle creek as well where a
bunch of other so a bunch of other
members of the seventh day adventist
also moved there uh kellogg senior so dr
john kellogg's dad uh opened a broom
factory there so there was that whole
thing
so uh because the kellogg family and
like i said at this point dr kellogg is
still a kid
uh because they thought that christ was
uh on his way back for real this time
you guys
uh they didn't really think that it was
all that important for their kids to go
to school or like be educated because
you know you're just going to be whisked
away to heaven you don't have to learn
nothing well you only think you need to
know is out of the bible
that's well yeah they were pretty much
very much that back in those days school
wasn't [ __ ] anyway probably yeah it
wasn't really kind of like there wasn't
really much of a formal yeah uh you know
it was very kind of like hit or miss and
particularly like in agrarian type or
rural type you know because a lot of
kids would just work on farms reading
writing arithmetic that's all you needed
to know that in the bible
cheryl says no alcohol or smoking or sex
i'm out yeah right it's like i don't
know how they get people to be into this
but okay
back in the olden days it sounds really
lame
back in the old days most people didn't
have a high school diploma and if you
had one it was kind of like graduating
from college
it was a big deal
even you know late 1800s early 1900s
yeah
zach says i know the woman whose baby
got snatched by a dingo in australia was
a seventh-day adventist that could make
a good show topic too i had totally
forgot about that
and then i was just kind of like because
i think when i mentioned that we were
gonna do a show about this somebody said
a dingo ate my baby it might have been
you yeah and then i was like oh yeah i
forgot that she was a seventh day
adventist that her little girl got taken
by dingo and she got blamed for it for a
really long time until they figured out
oh actually it really was a dingo
because it's australia but uh yeah we
should probably do a show about that i
mean i don't i don't know how
complicated well i guess it would they
made a movie about it so i guess we
could do a show about it there's
probably all kind of like interesting
little nooks and crannies they didn't
think zebras would they didn't think
dingoes existed
i don't think it was i don't think that
they didn't think that dingos existed i
think that they just thought that she
was using that as an excuse
um because she killed her baby i don't
know it's been like a long time since i
read about that i made a believer that a
dingo did eat the baby do you remember
no i don't remember okay it would i feel
like it was a long time before they
actually like sorted all of that out
because they blamed her for a long time
like she had actually killed the baby
and like because the baby was gone you
know i mean because the dingo doctor
took it yeah so and ate it
so that's [ __ ] up it's unusual that a
dog would do that but it was a wild dog
i guess well he was hungry i mean that's
that's terrible but
they don't know that's a human baby
they're just like it looks like a little
pork roast so i'm gonna have it look
like a little turkey
i mean i know that's awful but they
don't but they don't know
they don't know they just see this food
um yeah
so yeah so what was i saying so the kids
the kellogg kids didn't really get any
formal schooling that much
because you know jesus is coming
now john kellogg as a kid was kind of uh
sickly
he did go to a public school for a
little while for like two years when he
was about nine years old um
and then when he was 11 he actually left
school and started uh sorting brooms in
his dad's broom factory
putting this broom over here and putting
that brim over that technical
i mean how how different were the brooms
i don't know this is a push broom and
this is a whistleblower
why can't that's we'll see that's what i
was wondering maybe
individuals
that's well like i'm assuming that they
made like whisk brooms for home use and
maybe push brooms for more
industrial i mean they sort themselves
right you would think yeah
but
maybe they just gave him it was like
busy work how do you go over there and
move the brooms around get out of our
hands sorting
maybe sorting doesn't mean what we what
we think it means yeah i mean i'm pretty
sure that word has a meaning yeah but
maybe
maybe it doesn't mean what we're
thinking it means
yeah sorting you know that might be you
know [ __ ] dispatching them sending
them out
you know what i mean
what the [ __ ] is going on out there the
[ __ ] are they having a part are they
having a party again
they just had a party can't give these
rednecks money okay when that [ __ ]
happens they just get loud
they're going to play it's true
yeah
the uh
sorting might mean like dispatching
sending [ __ ] is you know like they've
ordered stuff and you've got to fulfill
the order
maybe that's what it is
okay but there's already a word for that
so i just i don't know maybe it's an
antique word tammy says the baby we're
talking about the the dingo ate my baby
case the baby was peeled out of its pjs
that's right uh and some experts had to
testify that a dingo could do that
that's right i had forgotten about that
detail that's why they thought that that
a human had done it because
they thought that a dog wouldn't be able
to like pull the baby out of the pajamas
uh yeah so there's that we should
probably do a show about that at some
point
so uh yeah sorting brooms that's what he
was doing
uh but he was real into
education and so was largely like
self-educated as a kid um he really
really liked to read not just the bible
he would read pretty much everything
and uh so like i said quite self-taught
read a little bit of everything
now uh when he was 12 years old uh the
whites who were again like higher up on
they had a publishing company
uh seventh-day adventist
and um
so he
when he was 12 john kellogg went to work
for them in their publishing company so
first he just like ran errands
and then he became what's called a
printer's devil which i think is very
funny uh it basically just means an
apprentice you know what i mean uh
you're running inks and [ __ ] like that
doing whatever they need to do and then
eventually he worked his way up to doing
like more editorial stuff like
proofreading and things like that
so uh he wanted to be a teacher actually
but so when he was 16 um he actually did
teach some school
and he did that for a little while and
then when he was 20
he um
started a teacher's training course
which i love this the training course he
went to was at a place called the
michigan state normal school yeah as
opposed to the abnormal school
they might have had gifted schools the
normal school slow school
this is the [ __ ] school yeah
oh my god the regular school that's
probably what they called it back then
because you know what i mean they
probably did school they probably did
call it that yeah
um let's probably play his play turn
back then probably just slow just slowed
just a little down well actually for a
time they they had a distinction between
idiot and imbecile and you could totally
use that as like um like a medical word
like it's the idiot school i don't know
if anything was called the idiot school
but they actually that was like a
medical like a technical term
that you're an idiot if your iq was
between
whatever it was but there was like a
whole there was idiot imbecile which
there was a whole thing [ __ ] more yeah
[ __ ] that was in there too so that's
nice uh yeah so yeah [ __ ] stands the
test of time too i'd like to see i'd
like to see who it was they're talking
about i'd probably be like yeah you got
them right
be honest
although the thing about it is that
what's going on you know well and yeah
we'll get into that too because uh
unfortunately dr kellogg was super into
that but
um i kind of feel like too though that
it wasn't always that the person was
just a dummy like sometimes they had
they were like mentally ill and i don't
really think they had the framework to
uh to diagnose anything like that so
maybe people nowadays that are just that
are perfectly you know intelligent and
you just have like you're on the autism
spectrum or something like that i think
they would get lumped in
with
you know being an idiot or something so
well they don't really talk or they
don't really you know so they must be
stupid well you could probably get in a
time machine and go back to those times
all futuristic and [ __ ] they'd if you
said something out of the ordinary
they'd probably grab you and [ __ ]
think you were insane well yeah that too
or [ __ ] you know he's an idiot and
[ __ ] you [ __ ] i just went back in time
150 years who you calling an idiot you
know
you could show up you don't know
anything
i'm from the 21st century and then
you're trying to show them some [ __ ]
like oh no that little trickery that's
nothing you know what i mean you show
them a [ __ ]
tablet they're showing my tablet and
they're like oh that didn't happen they
would be in denial
or they would be like [ __ ] yeah
i don't think they'd go and they'd burn
you alive
i don't think they'd go witch they would
just look at that and they go ah that
that's something from europe you know
this one that's one of those fancy
europeans yeah that's some fancy [ __ ]
from europe see this is why even if we
invented a time machine and people said
hey you want to go back in time no thank
you yeah no thank you depends on who it
is you're going to see
depend on who who was even somebody that
seems cool like from our point of view
like in the modern era
yeah i'd be i'd be hesitant because you
know just to get to that dude's house
you might have to like navigate some
some [ __ ] up situations and i'm not i
don't have the patience for that i just
don't
go back to go like hang out with [ __ ]
benjamin franklin that dude's [ __ ]
farting
farting at the table and then writing a
poem about it
taking his clothes off taking an air
bath
fat ass you know what i mean
out there [ __ ] with his windows wide
open women walking by and [ __ ]
pulling it
because he said he did that you know
that he did that he was doing that [ __ ]
he was a total person he was a [ __ ]
fur
maybe he liked him though he was he was
living his best life yeah
oh my god
so he could talk his way up a skirt or
two well yeah he was kind of famous for
that well he you know he had to eat
he didn't look too good but i mean you
know
that just goes that just goes to show
yeah he was probably like happening he
said he was hot when he was young he was
a big dude plus everybody liked
everybody liked the raccoon hat yeah he
made that [ __ ] up
he made the french believe that all
americans were raccoon hats so he kind
of they're like oh exotic i thought that
[ __ ] was exotic well yeah well i guess
it was he was trying to be like we're
not wearing that lady you understood
[ __ ] franklin understood the concept
he was way ahead of his time he
understood the concept of branding
and [ __ ] the american colonies had no
brand
so he branded it yeah and part of the
brand
was [ __ ] skin hats yeah and [ __ ]
country reason and [ __ ] being down to
earth yeah i'm down home [ __ ]
wearing black clothing black and white
clothing none of this fancy red and blue
that's for those effeminate french you
had to be serious you know i mean they
did that kind of [ __ ]
i'm serious in my nakedness in farting
yeah
i'm just
they didn't say that he farted
i'm just saying he wrote like a whole
thing about farting he did yeah okay i
didn't know about that part but i'm just
saying like i could imagine you see this
is how even back then
intelligent i am
i could sense a farter when i saw his
face
i saw that face and i said you didn't
even know that he wrote about what's
going on
i think
he even wrote like a big long thing if
it's been a while but um i'm pretty sure
he wrote a thing
he was trolling it wasn't true but he
wrote a thing about how he invented this
thing that like what'd you do like you
stuck in your underwear to make your
fart smell like perfume or to make them
smell good or something and i was like
that's funny but it's like that's
actually kind of a good idea yeah
i just looked at that dude pictures of
that dude that dude looks like a farmer
that dude sits around for him
and and i was like she's with that dude
out of the can yeah if i met that dude
it'd probably be disappointing because
i'd [ __ ] show up and you [ __ ]
stake the place up you fart and he's
looking at me laughing you know what i
mean yeah he's just like you know moving
like one cheek like
and he's trying to pour you some brandy
trying to have like an educated
conversation he gets all scientific with
your ass and it farts yeah excuse me
he's like rick i think he's like i think
he's like
you're not like rick sarah from the damn
from dan bell yeah yeah from another
dirty room
that's what he was like
yeah yeah i could see that because rick
sarah is kind of like that too he's like
really intelligent intelligent and he
knows all this stuff but then like he's
just completely shameless and gross yeah
yeah he just laughs but that's why i
mean that's why he's funny though
because it's like it's an entertaining
like juxtaposition yeah i had franklin
right i knew what i was i knew i was
dealing with yeah he was totally that
type of dude
we should do a show about ben franklin
ben franklin and his
and his uh you know lively farting but
uh yeah so where was i oh okay normal
school so that's where we got distracted
i try to get back through my notes and
be like yep that's where we lost it and
sometimes when i'm reading through my
notes before we do the show like the
morning of the show i'm always kind of
like i see the sentence and i was like
should i take that out because i kind of
feel like we're going to go off on this
whole hour like [ __ ] digression
because of that sentence but
whatever that's
people like that so i guess so whatever
uh so yeah
so he goes and does the training course
at the normal school as opposed to the
abnormal school
and but what ended up happening then was
that uh the rest of his family and also
uh the whites who were like i said high
up in the kind of uh seventh-day
adventist
you know people
they were like no you know what you
should do you and your brother and our
kids and all this other [ __ ] you guys
should all go to medical school
because what they wanted to do
was that they wanted to
they were still like into the religion
thing but like i said seventh day
adventists were very like health
conscious
in a time when that was
not super mainstream
so but then they were kind of worried
they're like well we want to
sort of um you know
bring these views like more mainstream
attention
and we kind of feel like we need some
more scientific backing for that so they
definitely wanted some people that were
seventh-day adventists to go to medical
school and get some actual scientific
training
so that they wouldn't just be coming out
being like hey we advocate all these
health practices not because we're
religious necessarily but because it's
the right thing to do science says so so
they were still trying to like they were
still trying to like toe that line so
they could get like a more mainstream
type of uh you know acceptance for their
views
so uh so that's what they did now uh
they had this thing this what later
became the battle creek sanitarium they
actually had it prior to that like the
whites owned it i believe or the
seventh-day adventist church owned it at
the time but at the time it was called
the western health reform institute so
that's what was there in battle creek
so what ended up happening was that the
whites actually paid for uh john harvey
kellogg to go to medical school so he
went to medical school the university of
michigan and then he went to the
bellevue hospital medical college in new
york city
so he graduated in 1875 uh with an
actual medical degree
and uh then in the next year in october
of 1876 uh they made him the director of
the western health reform institute and
then a year after that he renamed it the
battle creek medical surgical sanitarium
uh he did have surgical knowledge he was
a surgeon uh and he did do like several
uh surgeries
successfully apparently uh so like i
said he wasn't necessarily a quack he
wasn't just like one of those people
that didn't know what they were doing
he did actually go to medical school he
could actually do surgeries things like
that mostly i think his specialty was
mostly
uh abdominal
uh you know gynecological that type of
stuff so like lower like you know the
lower part of your body was kind of his
specialty but he did other things as
well uh so
uh he actually coined the term as i said
sanitarium calling it that uh because he
wanted it to evoke
a hospital but also
you know a health spa type of thing
which is essentially what it was
it was kind of like
as it went on i kind of feel like
because at first they would kind of take
anybody i think like even if you were
poor and stuff like you didn't
necessarily have to pay but i think like
later on they did have a lot of really
famous people like like i said like
presidents and you know like amelia
earhart people like that uh would stop
by there because it was like very trendy
to go by there and get like all your
health [ __ ] you know done you know what
i mean
uh and they had all kind of different
stuff and it was it's a massive massive
place it was a massive place and they
had just like tons of people on staff
doing like [ __ ] massages they had
their own
uh you know cooks that they had their
own like [ __ ] cooking school and
everything
so the thing about kellogg and again
this is kind of going back to his
seventh-day adventist thing
but a little bit i mean he'll get into
some like hot water with him later on
but his big thing was he thought that
the bible and science were in harmony
which
not really but okay but he actually did
believe that some of the stuff that said
in the bible uh was true and could be
proved scientifically so he was trying
to marry those two things together
rather than there being this sort of
like conflict between the two so he's
talking about the fundament and the flat
and the flat earth and all that see i
don't know though is he going with this
that's what i mean and well the weird
thing is that i mean as time went on
this would actually cause like quite a
large uh schism
within the seventh day adventist because
uh him and some of the other medical
doctors that had gone to actual medical
school and had some scientific training
would sort of go off in a little more
scientific direction like they believed
in evolution and things like that and
then some of the more like religious
seventh-day adventists did not like that
so
they would get kicked out like later on
so that it this actually did cause quite
a big
uh stir like later on like in the very
very early 20th century this is the
[ __ ] funny thing
in the more modern eras
christians who are becoming scientific
trying to make or trying to find the
science in the bible and
like he said that there's harmony
between the two
no man
no yeah you really have to like do some
some stretching to like make that work
that's a modern concept only a modern
person would have thought that if you
went back to the second century
okay
when that's when a lot of the new
testament stuff is starting to be
compiled
and even
even the stuff that ended up in the old
testament where it was really not as old
as a lot of people think it is
that was a certain genre of literature
even in the ancient world that wasn't
even considered science back then
it was a genre of literature
romans
and in the roman empire they would make
up a brand new
religion not a whole cloth
to fulfill a market an a a damn market
void or a demand in the market
and they would write that [ __ ] up
in a particular style
that the people of that era instantly
recognized it for what it was that it
was spiritual writing
they didn't even
in the time that they were writing that
it was never
intended to be looked at
under the eye of scientific scrutiny
that was not what it would just like
today you write that's not what it's for
that's not what it's for
because the romans had science
the ancients had all kinds of science
they knew that it would the the it was
divided even back then
that's not what religious scripture was
for
it was
like morality tales and like uh the
codification
of of a religious doctrine or cultural
values yeah i guess exactly it's just
like star wars star wars a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away it's setting
the story up the audience knows this
didn't happen
the same way with these religions
when they first appeared people knew
that they didn't that they didn't happen
when they got older a lot of people
thought that they did happen and then
maybe these stories were based upon old
kings of the past like uh they thought
maybe like jupiter or zeus was based
upon an old king sometime
it's called euhemorization you know um
but even real educated romans and greeks
knew that
the gods that they believed in as given
to them in their scriptures were not
historical
that's not what it was we're not like
legitimately true in the same way that
you know this is when we plant to grow
potatoes
right it's not what it was for
they were kind of like cross between
they were cultural artifacts
about history and values that's what
they were for
yeah it's just like a way of passing on
the culture passing on knowledge sure
which i i think that most people did
whether they could uh articulate that or
not i think most people did understand
that distinction a second or third
century christian if they were to see
like christians of the 18 and 1900s in
the 20th century trying to [ __ ]
prove their religion using science they
that the ancients would have laughed at
that like what are you talking about no
you know i mean you're doomed to fail
yeah it's kind of like
like i said i used to kind of get a lot
of uh entertainment value
out of reading a lot of the um
you know this the scientific kind of
[ __ ] for like creationists would use and
it's like i love that they tried to be
like no we're not creationists we're
into intelligent design it's the same
thing um they just rebranded it so it
sounded more like scientific
and the ridiculous
[ __ ]
reaching ass arguments they come up with
and just picking on the tiniest little
like minutia right of it's like well
this well god must have created stuff
because this particular beetle there's
no way that it could have evolved this
particular venom or whatever and it's
like they're just picking on these tiny
little things like because they're just
you know the the
kind of room for uh for religion in the
scientific framework it's just getting
smaller and smaller so it's like they're
trying to fill in the gaps with these
little bitty
you know little things and it's just
like not working out what they're doing
is they're trying to say our religion is
real we can prove it scientifically if
you look here in the creation story it
says this was created before that and
that must have happened because look
blah blah blah when they're totally
taking the damn genesis story out of
context totally
there's two different creation stories
given in genesis
okay um
they both couldn't have happened it's
just that the the um
um
i'm kind of drunk so i'm trying to
describe trying to [ __ ] talk about
scripture and intelligent design
the
the creation of stories in genesis they
don't really say anything it's just
poetic it just says life was created by
god through a process that's all it says
that's pretty much that's all the
anxious and then suddenly the world
appeared yeah
well actually no it says this happened
and the world appeared and then then the
god made the sun and but it's a story
it's not meant to be it's not meant to
be a scientific description well it's
almost kind of like it's it's like a
placeholder is what it is it's like we
don't really know how the thing but this
is like a cool story that we're kind of
like leaving in there until we figure it
out later they're just saying god
created the god created the world and
people and animals and and this is how i
got here it's not a big deal
it was they never intended some dude
thousands of years later try to put that
underneath scrutiny and go well they
didn't think like ken hovind was gonna
open a [ __ ] museum and put a [ __ ]
saddle on a triceratops right okay i'm
pretty sure that even they would have
laughed at him two thousand years ago
just like we're laughing at him now is
that dude well a fruit bat has
a fruit bat has sharp teeth and fangs so
therefore a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] um tyrannosaurus rex was a
vegetarian
no
not at all uh afraid not
[Laughter]
i challenge i challenge an animal that
big to get the [ __ ] daily protein
requirements to sustain that mass by
eating [ __ ] vegetables you're [ __ ]
tripping well only a child who doesn't
understand how nutrition works
would think that something's that
although there were some big ass
dinosaurs
yeah the [ __ ] the uh the other one
didn't actually exist they had put two
animals together i think yeah yeah yeah
brontosaurus right yeah
that's and then yeah they don't call it
that thing was doing basically what an
elephant does yeah it's like it's a
grazer it's just grazing yeah right
but if you
but you know
you look at something like a raptor or a
[ __ ]
you know like a velociraptor or a
[ __ ] big old tyrannosaur those
two-legged ones
those were definitely predatory ambush
predators you know
yeah it's like why they have this big
ass [ __ ] teeth
obviously that's not they're not eating
grass with that [ __ ]
they don't have to be bipedal if they're
[ __ ] grazing fourth drawdown says
only the boring dinosaurs for
vegetarians
yeah you don't that's true if you're
grazing then you don't need to be
bipedal
yeah because you can just like hang
around like a cat yeah you could just
stand there with your men you just stand
there and like eat the grass right like
i said you don't need big-ass teeth you
don't need ankles
some of them just had flat teeth well i
as far as i know and like i said it's
when i was a kid i was super into
dinosaurs so i haven't kept up as much
like with the dinosaur science like for
the last few years but i was under the
impression that that was one of the
first ways they could tell if it was an
herbivore or a carnivore obviously
because of their teeth because
herbivores just have like flat teeth for
like chewing grainy teeth i'm grinding
the teeth yeah
look at something like those raptors you
definitely ambush predators
yeah especially the big ones just the
smaller raptors
probably something like pack animals
kind of like wolves
that makes most sense
cheryl says i can't believe that
creationism is taught in christian
schools how can you legally teach kids
[ __ ] honestly
it doesn't even bother me like look if
you've got if you got kids and you're
paying to send them to private school
and you don't care that they're never
going to be able to maybe get a decent
job because they're idiots who think
that like cavemen rode around on
dinosaurs i guess that's on you i mean i
guess it's not you know it's it's sad
that like the kids gonna have to go
through life like that but the problem i
have is when they try to like push it
into public schools which all of our tax
sellers pay for i'm like you just you
keep that [ __ ] to yourself you
homeschool your kids if you want
um i'm not having it
if i had a kid and that they were going
to public school i don't want to learn
in that crap i'm gonna protest what
jenny said because i went to a christian
military academy [ __ ] great education
but they taught us both
okay they taught us both
they we had we had chapel we learned
bible stuff we learned all those bible
stories but then we also learned things
like evolution at the same time
but see i'm not bothered by i'm not
bothered by teaching people about bible
stories the problem i have is in a
public school is if you're saying this
[ __ ] really happened because obviously
it did not i think well here's the thing
they never told us that [ __ ] really
happened they told us that these were
articles of faith
that's what they told us
yeah well like i said i don't it's just
that that's just the bible story and and
they we were always taught those stories
as if they were um fables or like
morality tales which i i don't have a
problem that's all it was and we never
really looked at things like
we never really looked at things like uh
the the creation stories as being
literal they were always figurative they
were like it's like poetry
you know
like the great flood
you know
yeah we didn't really think the great
flood actually happened
you know what i mean some people do
though
but that's on them i know but here's
another thing
would that keep you from getting a good
job no
it wouldn't well it depends on what kind
of job you get most most people have
good jobs and those good jobs are at
[ __ ] walmart
that's that's not a good job
well dependent on like depends on who
you are yeah okay
not like i said we live in a world of
indians not chiefs not everybody can be
a chief
and you can't you can't educate
everybody you'd have a [ __ ] up society
if you did
especially if you educated them all to
the level of a [ __ ] doctor they'd all
fight and kill each other over [ __ ]
high-end jobs and it wouldn't be anybody
to do manual labor
you just can't have an organized society
like that
and the thing is most people aren't
happy with that kind of stuff most
people don't want to know that kind of
thing they like to have fun and have a
artistic life where they're
chasing [ __ ] the opposite sex and
having kids and [ __ ] buying houses
and
making cars and
looking pretty that's what they do
that's all humans are
and i say this because i'm intelligent
and intelligent people
are [ __ ] very unhappy for the most
part dumb people [ __ ] have a good
time
slasher fred says one of these days you
on your live show should do a review for
the movie westworld we did a review of
westworld i don't think it was live when
live but we did one a long time ago
great movie that was the original
terminator
yes
was the original the original jurassic
park yeah it is kind of that too it's
the original jurassic park in the
original terminator yeah it's like a
theme park that's kind of like i've
still i've still been made to like watch
because didn't they do like a they did a
series of it that i heard was actually
quite good yeah same writer though did
one called the demon seed that's even
better yeah we did we reviewed yeah did
the diva seed also we did review that
one as well
uh proteus cheryl said uh so glad there
aren't dinosaurs today that would suck
yeah it would
um i mean you know they're never birds
yeah but you know you know what she is
those big dinosaurs right yeah you don't
want to be going around and having like
a [ __ ] t-rex turn your [ __ ] head
off that wouldn't be fun
um and then slasher fred said if you
guys ever seen that movie quest for fire
i haven't it's like it was a long time
ago though it was a good movie uh a long
time ray don chung spent half moving
[ __ ] naked running around and that's
all that matters it's all that matters
looking like he's in like his like in
his natural self because that dude looks
like a [ __ ] neanderthal to begin with
well that's why he gets those kind of
like roles all the time that's right
he's like making that work for him wait
back in the hockey motherland back back
when the honky motherland was [ __ ]
pure pure with his neanderthal dna
the original honkies
camp guy says i refer to my chickens as
uh they just lizards lizards yeah well
we call the sandhill cranes i call them
the dinosaur birds yeah because they
look like dinosaurs they're like four
three or four feet tall
so uh so yeah so we've got actually some
some dinosaurs were lizards and other
dinosaurs are closer to birds
well yeah it was a different i mean the
ones that chickens evolved from that was
one particular branch well because like
i said dinosaurs weren't one just like
monolithic thing there was like a whole
bunch of it was a whole yeah
different than it was millions of years
yeah and then they were almost two at
that time yeah they were just they were
just tended to be very small and
honestly um it's and i've said before
that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] meteor or whatever that
wiped out most of the dinosaurs you know
over time
uh was the best thing that ever happened
because it had that not hit
probably we would not be here the
mammals would i don't think would have
ever grown anything probably not yeah
probably not i mean it might have
something else might have happened but
it wouldn't have happened the same way
those dinosaurs had a head start they
never would have got big enough
because you know the dinosaurs are
occupying all the [ __ ] top predator
slots
so they never would have got big enough
they had to survive by staying small
being underneath the ground being like
rats gophers that type of [ __ ] yeah like
running around filling all those little
niches yeah they had insects that were
bigger than [ __ ] mammals you know
yeah well i think that too was because
the uh oxygen content was higher in the
air yeah well not only that the co2 was
[ __ ] way high yeah there's a lot of a
lot of [ __ ] you hear today or the
deadly co2 co2 is a life-giving gas the
more co2 you have in the dam
atmosphere the more green plants will
grow
the the harder chitin will become so
insects can grow huge you had i don't
like that you had yeah but it wouldn't
happen with our presence the [ __ ]
roaches are big enough as it is i don't
need one that's like as big as me yeah
we had roaches that were about a foot
long yeah yeah thank you you had uh the
big old dragonfly dragon flies with a
five foot wings they were as big as like
a hawk yeah
bigger that was it that would be [ __ ]
crazy five foot wingspan they could take
a bite out of you the size of an apple
yeah no thanks um no
you [ __ ] and then the oxygen was
[ __ ]
real [ __ ] strong the atmospheric
pressure would have been more and it was
hot real hot
again i don't think we could have
survived it because if some people said
that up around the equator it had been
100 humidity
and around the equator we've been
raining 24 hours a day
man could you imagine that and the
[ __ ]
the uh
the the continents hadn't hadn't [ __ ]
separated yet so there's basically one
big land mass and across the center of
it
around the equator it was just a
constant rainstorm
and it would have been hot like 120
degrees
because of all that co2
but it was a lot of co2 but there was a
lot of oxygen
which would have meant that you didn't
mean need much lung to breathe so we
would have got there you'd have a lot of
endurance because you but god damn it's
a real oxygen enriched environment
and that allowed those animals to get
that big because the dinosaur couldn't
get that big in today's environment
there wouldn't have been enough oxygen
it was a different planet
cheryl says there would be huge shits
all over see that's something that
occurred to me even as a kid because i
was really into dinosaurs and i was like
reading books about them like man it
must have just big huge piles yeah but
they had stuff eating those huge shits
they weren't there for well they still
have that now i'm just saying
i was out turning the horses out one
time to pasture a few years ago and
there's a big old [ __ ]
pile of [ __ ] horse dogs steaming i
turned my back on i heard something boom
and turned around and looked and there
was a [ __ ] gold bald eagle [ __ ]
had hit it full on with her [ __ ]
claws and was tearing through the
[ __ ] horse [ __ ] and i'm going what
the [ __ ] and then when it was done it
flew off i thought there was something
in there
i'd never seen an eagle do that
when it hit it sounded like a damn car
had to boom
and [ __ ] there was
i see you know the damn apple so the
apples went [ __ ] flying
and it was throwing throwing [ __ ] like
that and didn't find anything and then
split
i guess there's a habit where
some kind of creature runs into the
[ __ ]
horse [ __ ] and hides in there and that
that eagle was looking for it well yeah
i mean obviously there had been some
precedent for that yeah because
otherwise there's nothing doing that
and it was close to me 20 feet
yeah dung beetles yeah see there's like
nature has little niches for for
everything well there's a little poop
bug it was looking for it
all right so
man my drink's empty i'll get you one i
need another one
so uh so yeah so we were talking about
how dr kellogg
uh actually did believe
that uh the christian faith uh seventh
day adventist the bible and everything
like that and science could be
reconciled uh that science would back up
a lot of religious uh kind of beliefs
now again the seventh day adventists you
know there was a lot of kind of conflict
with them about that because
because of this contingent of
seventh-day adventists that they had
actually like sent to medical school to
get science training for that specific
reason um it kind of
a little bit bit him in the ass in the
end because you know when you get some
scientific training now they're just
kind of like oh well we still believe
all the god stuff but now we have all
this science stuff and so some of the
religious people were thinking oh well
maybe the ones that had the science
training are getting like less religious
and they're having these maybe heretical
ideas so there was like a little bit of
a conflict brewing there which would uh
come to fruition like later on very
early in the 20th century
so
uh at this point i wanted to talk about
this isn't a huge this is a little bit
of a side track but
uh somebody brought this up and it is
related to this whole kellogg thing
this is um the i guess it's called the
eurantia book uh and he was saying that
i hoped that you know that he hoped that
i brought it up so i'm gonna bring it up
a little bit because it does actually
have something to do with
um not so much the weird health stuff
they were doing there but it does have
something to do thank you with um
with the battle creek uh sanitarium and
with the weird um
kind of
maybe conflict between
science and supernatural i guess like it
has that kind of uh thing to it
so uh so here's what i was talking about
like the urantia
connection so there's this guy
named william sadler
now he actually ended up moving to
michigan when he was a teenager to work
at the battle creek sanitarium and he
met john kellogg who was at the time the
head of it
um and john kellogg became his mentor
and william sadler even ended up
marrying
uh kellogg's niece whose name is lena in
1897.
now william sadler also graduated from
medical school but this like early we're
jumping ahead a little bit but he um
graduated from medical school in 1906
and he actually ended up practicing
medicine in chicago and his wife was
also a doctor so she also uh practiced
there as well
uh and he was also a seventh-day
adventist as with as was his wife uh
they were both in it for a couple of
decades
but when um
john kellogg in 1907 again we're
skipping ahead and i'll come back to
this but when he was disfellowshipped
meaning he was like kicked out of
seventh-day adventists like the formal
uh you know framework or whatever in
1907
william
sadler left as well because that was
like his
mentor his hero or whatever
now william sadler and his wife would go
on to become kind of like speakers
orators and they he wrote like a whole
bunch of uh books like 40 books or
something like that and again he was
talking very much about
holistic health practices which as i
said
it was kind of a thing but i feel like
it wasn't mainstream i mean the [ __ ]
that they came up with at the battle
creek sanitarium i was actually kind of
shocked because you know i knew about
the cereal and i kind of knew about
um some of the stuff that they talked
about but a lot of the stuff that
kellogg came up with specifically
that i mean people just take it for
granted nowadays but
he was really kind of like ahead of his
time particularly is concerned with like
health food and stuff but yeah so uh so
yeah we'll get into that but yeah it's a
whole holistic health kind of issue
now
this urantia book thing
though is kind of interesting
so apparently at some point and this is
almost going off into like
spiritualism direction a little bit or i
ca it kind of reminds me like maybe some
edgar cayce [ __ ] it's kind of like that
because it's kind of like sciencey but
it's also like supernaturally as well
so apparently the story goes that
sometime between 1906 and 1911.
so this woman uh unnamed came to william
sadler and said
you know my husband when he's asleep
um
he makes like all these weird movements
and like maybe talks like in a weird
voice and stuff
so they determine that maybe he's
talking to a visitor from another planet
because of course that's the first thing
you would jump to so you know
again these weird seventh-day adventists
okay whatever
so um so sadler he gets all these other
people that also had medical training
and they come and like watch this dude
sleeping
now at some point i think that at first
they were kind of thinking
well at first sadler thought that maybe
it was just like fake or he was just
like had some kind of psychological
problem or something but then like the
more he listened to him he's like no
maybe we're on to something here he
didn't think that he was necessarily a
medium like he was channeling dead
people or whatever but he thought maybe
that he was channeling either living
people or
quote unquote celestial beings so like
angels god i don't know so he thinks
like this this [ __ ] sleeping dude is
like uh telling like some [ __ ]
knowledge from
the outer spheres or some [ __ ]
um
so again now to give props to sadler uh
even though he was a seventh-day
adventist he was also a man of science
he was a doctor and so he did
apparently try to uh find a scientific
thing he's like well maybe he just has
psychological problems maybe you know
something but apparently as time went on
he became more convinced that something
strange was going on
so uh so yeah so him and these other
doctors that he knew would come and like
watch this dude sleep and like you know
sort of take note of
[ __ ] that he was saying
and uh apparently too
this gave me like [ __ ] uh joseph
smith mormon vibes here but
uh 1925 and again jumping ahead i'm
gonna go back to the kellogg stuff in a
minute this is like tangentially related
but i'm talking about it because
somebody asked me about it
and i so i wanted to include it
so apparently uh these
papers start turning up in this sleeping
dude's house
and at first they think that this dude
is like writing this stuff on the papers
like as like an automatic writing type
of deal
and it's apparently some kind of
again like messages from the outer
spheres or what have you
um
so william sadler he took the papers to
his house
and he wouldn't let anybody else take
him like i said i think that's what
reminded me of like the mormon [ __ ] with
the golden tablets and whatnot he's like
yeah i've got him in my thing but you
can't see him though i just found him in
my yard
it just it kind of reminded me of that
um but he did let some people read them
now again he thought that it was
automatic handwriting but then he was
like well no maybe there's something
else going on
so again he starts having all these
people come over like every sunday now
every sunday they have like a formal
thing where everybody comes over and
they talk about this dude's case and
they think that they have some kind of
thing and they have like figure out
questions they want to ask him
um
some of the observers i think william
sadler knew who the dude was and like a
couple other people did but i think they
kind of tried to keep his uh identity
under wraps
some people thought that it was maybe
uh the man they were talking about no
one's entirely sure they think maybe it
was wilfred kellogg who was
the husband of
lena's sister elena kellogg's sister
anna so again relation to john kellogg
there
um
so later
in the uh
19 in 1955 they actually put out this
book called the eurantia book which was
apparently all of these writings that
this sleeping dude had come up with like
i said very edgar casey type situation
um and some
some places if you go to like the
[ __ ] i don't think the urantia book
has its own wikipedia page but i think
it's like on the william sadler
wikipedia page
and some people consider the urantia
book
almost like
a
a second bible or a bible substitute in
some ways because it's supposed to be
some kind of like
new revelation that god gave to humanity
um and it's supposedly helping people
like evolve to a higher form of life
and one of sadler's quotes about this
particular book
was that
the book the book is quote unquote
essentially christian and entirely
harmonious with known scientific facts
so again there's that kind of like
trying to marry
religion and science again which was
very much
in this uh you know this particular um
you know kind of scene of people we're
trying to do that is the religion
harmonizing with the science or is the
science just permissible under the
religion
you can look at is that a distinct
distinction without a difference yes
there is a difference yeah there is a
difference because you can come up with
a science and say okay this is what
really works and this does not violate
our religions
okay that that and that and that could
be true
another thing what would be more
difficult to be true is to make up a
science based upon our religion
and have that science work that's very
different
and i think that would be very hard yeah
i'm going through the book of daniel and
what i learned there i will make a
science based upon it
and it will heal you see how that works
you know we've had many comments on here
uh somebody who graduated from a
catholic school yeah you get a good
education she said i have heard yeah
i've known some people
when i was talking about creation of
itself that's mostly that's not a
catholic thing that's more like a
fundamentalist yeah that's uh christian
that's a different there's a distinction
there is yeah because like i said i've
known a lot of catholic school and they
generally get like a pretty decent
education yeah depending on what part of
the country they're in i went to it like
a non-denominational protestant style
protestant-style military academy
southern california military cat is
famous that's where they filmed over the
top or part of the over
over the top that was the that's the arm
wrestling the arm lesson was still up
that was my middle school
and that was a great school it was all
signal on top of signal did you have an
arm wrestling class no no
oh come on you should have left but some
of those guys ended up in hollywood and
some of them are listeners right now
[ __ ] and they're making movies but uh
no we got a good education there man we
had fun at that school
it was like boy scouts and middle school
and um even had elementary that was
mixed into it too and i think it went up
to like 10th grade but i left in uh
eighth grade um
but now we had a good time there and got
a real good education there but they
separated the religion from the school
you know what i mean like it had a
religious elements but you only learned
religious stuff in a special class we
call chapel
okay you sing songs and you listen to
bible stories
but there's taught to you as cultural
artifacts and fables it's not science
right and like i said i don't have a
problem with that at all because i think
even in my high school which was a
public school
they had a class called world religions
yeah and they also taught about uh
religions and humanities classes because
i had one of those too and they just
talked about all different kind of like
it's kind of how it was taught to us in
in a way which i don't have a problem
with that this is the this is our if
you're a christian then this is your
religion these are your traditions
but that doesn't excuse you from
learning about
[ __ ] chemistry and [ __ ] you know
evolution and natural selection yeah see
that's the problem i have the problem i
have is these people that think the
bible is literally true right and that's
all you need to know yeah and that's all
you need to know so that's what i have
an issue with not so much and honestly i
think people should
learn about uh particularly christianity
or learn about like uh world religions
ideally because it's so ingrained in our
culture right um that really you need
some understanding about it just like
every culture needs an understanding of
their own like mythologies and stuff
because it says a lot about uh the
people that came up with it it says a
lot about the people that created it
their history and stuff like that so i
think it's important to you we've got
islamic
we got islamic subscribers like saad
he's in
saudi arabia
studying for his doctorate and he will
tell you that islam does not teach you
how to do surgery
okay
islam is a cultural artifact in a legal
system that's what it is
okay
but it is not fully encompassed is
that's not science
okay
it's the same thing but that's that's
that's how i was taught
in school that's wes we saw christian
christianity as
i
tradition
yeah i always kind of considered it the
same yeah i always kind of considered it
the same as learning like your
you know your great novels from your
culture your great poetry or learning
something like that washington or
learning about well i mean that was that
was a dude that really existed though
right so i'm just i'm talking more about
learning your cultures like folklore or
learning your cultures like like i said
you're great writers right uh you know
in poetry and stuff yeah i like that
kind of stuff yes george washington
really existed but the thing is though
is that most of what a lot of the things
that are taught about george washington
uh is apocrypha well yeah that's
folklore yeah that's the truth yeah that
didn't happen well it's the same thing
in christianity yeah a lot of it is
apocryphal stories and some of them are
real people right and but a lot of them
aren't but
they don't make that distinction because
that's not on
that's not how you're supposed to look
at
at religion religion is to give you
cultural context of where you came from
as a culture that's all it is
and it's trying to hold yourself up to a
certain standard
it's tradition
that's all it is this you can't make it
more than what it is
now nietzsche goes on to that's good
what
i agree with what nietzsche says
you should put
moral restrictions and religions onto
people when they're young
so they can learn to free themselves
from it
okay
because they need the
they need the discipline when they're
young to hold themselves together when
they're weak
young people are weak okay they need
something to believe in to protect them
until they're wise enough to go out on
their own and be able to operate outside
the confinements of
tradition you i'm talking about
yeah yeah or at least a lot of people
are like that and it does keep you out
of trouble until you until you're in
your 20s you know what i mean that's
what that's and most people didn't
really
if you look at history that's what it
that's what it was for
once you reach the age of reason you
ended up making your own decisions you
didn't really worry about too much
what some dude a long time ago said
that's how it is cheryl says i spent
four years in the mormon church learned
all i needed to know religious people
are mostly bad [ __ ] yeah sure it's a
symptom of mental illness yeah uh in
some regards yeah i'm gonna agree with
you on that you try to make a life on
that there's a problem
like i said i don't have a problem with
people having that if it's if it knows
its place right it's got a place and
that's it yeah like i said don't be
trying to do like surgery on this i just
read the bible so i can like take out
your gallbladder right yeah no that's
that's not how that's gonna go i read
this book so therefore give me all of
your daughters they're all my wives
yeah yeah i'm not i'm the yeah that's
not gonna fly sorry right uh yeah
captain it was captain blair that asked
me about the iranian book uh the
eurentia book says in pre-history there
were giant birds that communicated with
humans cue the winged serpent now i just
made that up and gave them rides like
joust well they should
if you're a big bird your purpose is to
give a [ __ ] a ride it's like hey
come on yeah
big ostrich or whoever come on now
but yeah so uh so i did want to like
bring that up so william sadler who like
i said was you know one of uh john
kellogg's proteges
uh he had actually left the adventist
church he left the adventist church when
john kellogg got disfellowshipped which
we'll get into a little bit um
but you know so he had actually left by
the time that he published the urantia
book in 1955
but a lot of the stuff that's in there
is
pretty consistent with uh seven
seventh-day adventist beliefs there's
some wacky [ __ ] in there too but there's
you know it's it's mostly kind of like
uh
you know annihilationism which i'm
guessing it's like oh the end of the
world is coming or whatever i will note
though that the authorship of this book
is or the papers that the book came from
is disputed with
a not insubstantial number of critics
thinking that maybe william sadler wrote
that [ __ ] himself which like i said is
giving me some
uh giving me some joseph smith vibes
right there so uh yeah all right so
let's get back to
dr john kellogg so let's talk about this
whole disfellowshipping thing because
that's what's something that i brought
up earlier
now what happened in 1903 and this is
going back to what we're talking about
the whole like conflict between science
and religion
um
they called this the pantheism crisis
i love how they had to give everything a
[ __ ] name
so uh
so john kellogg was one of the ones at
the forefront of this because he's still
a seventh-day adventist but again he's
trying to
uh you know sort of just consolidate or
say that there's no conflict between uh
science and religion at this point um
and there was also kind of like a big
controversy over the ownership of the
sanitarium because the seventh day
adventist church did own the sanitarium
at the time but kellogg was running it
and he was kind of like the guy that was
associated with it most uh prominently
so um and it had kind of gotten
important too like over the years
because as the years went on and the
sanitarium became more popular and they
started attracting more celebrities and
more kind of like you know wealthy
people so it was kind of bringing in
some cash so it was you know causing
some friction there as well
uh so at this point um
in 1902 like early 1902
the battle creek sanitarium actually
burned down
um
now most of the people got out
uh but
the property loss was about four hundred
thousand dollars in 1902 money
uh which was about twice how much uh the
value that it was insured for
so what happened then was that dr
kellogg he had written a book called the
living temple
and he had made quite a bit of money
from it
so he basically took all of his
royalties from that to help rebuild the
hospital and at that point he's kind of
like well i paid all this money to
rebuild it so he kind of felt more of
like an ownership about it although i
will say one thing about dr john kellogg
is that
he doesn't seem to have i mean i'm sure
that he wasn't like you know
living in a refrigerator box or anything
like that but
he did seem to not have been all that
concerned about making money off of his
patents
and off of his
um you know inventions like his cereals
and stuff like that that he made later
on
as i said he seemed very much like a
true believer and he just invented all
this stuff for a purpose like because he
was trying to
uh kind of get his views into the
mainstream like on health particularly
and so
it didn't really seem like i said i'm
sure that he wasn't turning money down
but it didn't really seem like his prime
motivator let's put it that way well
he's personally right [ __ ]
needed some damn fiber
like i said
he was like he had some wacky ideas
but some of the [ __ ] that he says he was
right about like like quite a bit of
stuff i will say that he was wrong about
quite a bit of stuff too but you can't
win them all you know what i mean when
you look at the diet of his era there
wasn't much fiber in it beef and maybe
some green vegetables well see the thing
about it and you know because kellogg's
so associated with corn flakes yeah no
for refrigeration either i mean you have
to think that when corn flakes were
invented which i'll get into like in
more depth in a little bit
but you have to think like people
weren't getting up in the morning and
eating just like a bowl of cereal or
something like that people were eating
like last night's leftovers they were
like heating up the meat piece of bread
and meat and maybe potatoes or something
like that like in fat and they were just
like eaten they didn't have like a
concept of like breakfast food you just
ate like whatever meat and [ __ ] was left
over from last night you reheated it in
the fat and you ate it who knows what
was up hung up in your damn intestines
from those flickering well that's the
point that he was trying to make it like
i said he was probably right about yeah
and they and did you need to shoot
yogurt up your butt probably not you all
know that i have a background as a cook
too i love to [ __ ] cook if you if you
if i see photographs and just read
recipes of the kind of [ __ ] they would
eat back then you wouldn't touch that
[ __ ] with a 10-foot pole most of it
the whole foods you could eat
some of the drinks that they drank
but no they weren't much of cooks man
and they just did not have a very diet
they just ate what yeah they just ate
whatever you're taking
a lot of [ __ ] for granted i mean they
were eating things that only came in
season not much fruit vet and vegetables
meat
yeah not too much
and bread and bread
and not much of it so yeah they're
they're probably pretty bunged up yeah
and they and
if you look at photographs of them these
were not massive people
very narrowly they're so constipated
if you look at the men they have very
narrow shoulders which is a sign of
mounted male
nutrition in early childhood
very little upper body mass
there was nobody built like me nobody
closest would have been maybe like louis
pandur
and that was until later
or i think his name was louie but his
last name was pandor
and uh then later on you had [ __ ] um
oh what's his name and even his
shoulders weren't as broad as mine uh
sandow
eugen sandow
and he was natural you know
uh no there were no
there was no injustice testosterone or
any uh performance enhancing drugs
he still had a pretty good frame you can
look him up eugene sandow
we did a whole show about that whole
show of him there's a lot of he he was a
strong man and
wrote fitness books how to trade
militaries and uh
he took a lot of good photos of himself
he made a living basically selling
selling nude
nude selfies basically
and going on tour uh but
quite the character quite the character
that's the best physique you could have
ever had in the 1800s
and he was eating a lot of [ __ ] he
ate a whole chicken a day and any other
kind of meat and he ate a lot of green
vegetables which is a very expensive
diet for those days
and bread
and his workout was his daily show
he was just strong he did the draw
strong mash out
no bench press so his chest isn't real
developed
but um
good physique he was the top top top
point zero one percent of the [ __ ]
human population most people looked like
eight-year-old children when it came to
upper body strength the men too
diet just wasn't there
and the kind of exercise they did just
wore you down more than build you up
you know
so guys like this coming about with
[ __ ] fiber in your diet and let's
worry about what we eat that was a
stepping stone to
fitness industry and health
well like i said that's what i'm saying
he's like way ahead of his time which
i'll get into in a bit like he had some
like [ __ ] whack-a-doodle ideas too
i'm not saying that um and some kind of
evil ideas also but most guys that came
up with good ideas were also [ __ ]
crazy that's what you had a bunch of
[ __ ] about that well you have to be a
little bit crazy to go that much against
the grain of uh your surrounding culture
i guess you have to be a little bit
crazy i'm gonna show a photography
greater or lesser degree i'm gonna show
a photograph of sandow just in case
people don't i mean we did do a show
about that yeah but that was a long time
ago we're talking about people right now
that was as good as you could get in the
1800s that's sandow he was the [ __ ] man
he was the [ __ ]
shout out
zach says i find if i eat anything
beyond cereal most of the time for
breakfast i'll feel like crap most of
the day yeah me too i don't really i i
don't like eating really early in the
morning um usually i just have a cup of
coffee
and that's about it sometimes i'll have
like a packet of oatmeal or something i
do now i do like brunch
like i do like a big heavy brunch
but i can't really eat all that much uh
early in the morning honestly we don't
usually eat until
uh one or so i don't usually eat
anything in the morning i usually have a
cup of coffee or two and that's about it
every now and then i'll have a boiled
egg cheryl says uh just the thought of
picking maggots out of your meat before
you ate it is enough to live on
vegetables yeah pretty much uh dom the
bomb jenny did you ever watch the road
to wellville i did but it was a long
time ago i actually meant to like
re-watch it before we did the show but i
didn't have time
but i had i have seen it rebecca saw
sandow went yeah damn i'd hit that
that's a [ __ ] rebecca said
yeah sandal was [ __ ] way ahead his
time for the 1800s got in trouble his
wife disowned him because of some
shenanigans that happened
some people have theorized that uh
he might have been doing some gay
prostitution on the side he was
definitely doing private showings for
men yeah we talked about that on the
show i kind of like they weren't they
may not have been here for the show so
i'm just saying okay go ahead jenny
doesn't let me talk about that no i'm
just saying that like we already did a
show about that yeah
that was like four or five hours long
okay like if it wasn't that long ago i'm
just saying we already did a show about
that okay
uh yeah captain blair says you should
drink boost or insure in the morning
i can't i can't stomach that kind of
[ __ ] man i can't really stomach a lot of
[ __ ] like really early in the morning
usually i just have like a cup of coffee
and that's about it
uh so yeah so [ __ ] kellogg he had
made so much money from this book that
he's like [ __ ] i'm gonna pay to like
rebuild the you know the [ __ ] that
burned down right so he did that
now
the thing about this book though was
that
whatever he said in it
uh because he wrote several books
but
when it was going to the printer
there was a commission
uh you know your seventh day adventist
they have their little
you know society of elders or whatever
the hell
and at least one of those dudes
read the manuscript and was like you
should not publish this because it's
heretical
so they didn't want him to do it because
you know kellogg was very associated
with seventh-day adventists they thought
that it would make them look bad i'm
assuming
so he says okay we'll [ __ ] you then i'll
just like print it privately
so what happened then though was that he
goes to like send it somewhere to get it
printed
and
the uh
place where the book was put together
like typeset and stuff that place burned
down was it arson
i don't know i'm not into conspiracy
theories maybe it was maybe the [ __ ]
burned down all the time back then i'm
not saying but wherever like you know so
so the book was going to be printed that
burned down too but
you know obviously he had another copy
so the book did come out in 1903
and when it came out ellen white who
again was uh kind of
you know dr kellogg's kind of start in
adventures you know he'd he'd worked for
them like at their publishing company
she came out and said
uh this book is heretical because it
advocates pantheism
so over the next couple years uh there
was a big schism developing between what
the advent is perceived as kellogg's
quote-unquote pantheism and his
belief that
medical science could be
uh married to
religious thing without any conflict and
the adventists were not really having
that
so there was kind of like a big
deal so this went on a couple of years
and then in 1907
uh dr kellogg got disfellowshipped which
is
you know you just got kicked out for
pretty much the same thing as they would
do to jehovah's witnesses or whatever
now this uh whole thing ended up
actually kind of splitting the church
now after this happens kellogg actually
did keep control of the sanitarium
and he was also running the american
medical missionary college
and so he just stayed doing that and he
didn't like
tell people that he wasn't a seventh-day
adventist he did actually still like
retain that belief system
and he
continued to promote that like through
the sanitarium and through his uh books
and his other work and stuff like that
because like i said they were very much
into
you know your body being a temple very
like a health-conscious uh type of
people
so uh what were these health things that
they advocated what they were very early
advocates of
vegetarianism
uh they didn't i don't think that they
like insisted that you be a vegetarian
like you couldn't eat meat
but they discouraged eating meat you
know what i'm saying they were very much
into vegetarians which like i said for
the time
was kind of a big thing because that's
mostly all people eat
was i kind of feel like just meat and
bread that was what they ate muslims
well you could trust it
yeah well that's another thing too it's
well it's just kind of like going back
around the 19th century where you're
probably safer if you drink beer instead
of water because the water would give
you like all kind of diseases because it
had [ __ ] in it and the beer at least was
safe
and if you saw them kill something and
cook it then you knew it was safe oh
so you know
and and yeah
i mean
you can have a very almost like a
ketogenic diet but you're going to be
[ __ ] low in fiber so he's right about
[ __ ] like corn flakes and bran and
vegetables they're right about it i
think a lot of the problems and me and
jenny touched about this on other shows
it even goes to our grandparents here in
the south they would overcook vegetables
[ __ ] crazy
they would cook [ __ ] spinach down to
a [ __ ] green slime it was disgusting
it didn't taste like anything no and
that came from the depression from the
depression era and their parents
which tells me
subsistence farming
yeah they were they were
fertilizing their fields with [ __ ]
human waste and they were getting sick
so they would overcook it to be sure
that's what it was which probably saved
their asses right to be honest but they
probably weren't enjoying their food no
it meant people meant their vegetables
tasted like [ __ ] and that people didn't
enjoy them so this guy's saying no eat
them vegetables well if you [ __ ] have
the right fertilizers you know sanitize
[ __ ] properly
you don't have to overcook a vegetable
and it they're a lot better when they're
raw or [ __ ] only very lightly steamed
or something you know although i don't
think the [ __ ] honkies of that arrow
knew much about steaming that was a
japanese thing
roasting or yeah or roasting even yeah
but [ __ ] steaming and vegetables are
[ __ ] great steam is the way to go
[Music]
but definitely not boiling no they just
went down the slime they would just boil
it down at nothing yeah it didn't taste
like anything no
no worse than nothing yeah it tasted bad
boiled [ __ ] boiled spinach tasted
like [ __ ] rotten snot or something it
was terrible
terrible well i've said i've said this
before but it's like for a long time i
thought i hated spinach just because
it was always boiled to death and it
smelled awful when it was cooking and it
tasted awful
but eating it raw in salads i'm like wow
this is delicious the only the only
greens my grandmother could cook were
brussels sprouts
and [ __ ] and turnip greens
spinach she [ __ ] cooked it to death
yeah
yeah uh black eyed peas of course peas
and edison count but for some reason
they automatically boiled spinach to
death yeah that was a
southern thing
maybe it's because spinach was canned a
lot and when it came out of a can it
looked like that so they would a lot of
vegeta well green vegetables don't taste
good out of a can i've eaten some stuff
out of a can like corn and potatoes and
stuff that tastes okay like not if
you're just like dumping it out on a
plate and eating it but if you put use
it in a recipe
then it's then it's
yeah like in a casserole or something
but i'm not a big fan of like green
vegetables in cans not really i think if
you're going to have green beans or peas
or something like that it's like fresh
ones around y'all never had a [ __ ]
southern brussels sprout it's a little
bitty round thing about the size of a
[ __ ] ping-pong ball it's like a
little bitty head of cabbage
and you cook it with butter and [ __ ]
bacon bits
and you have the drippings from it in
the little dish oh it's just so good
just eat a whole brussels sprout on the
end of [ __ ] fork oh that's good
yeah that was another vegetable that i
thought i didn't like until i actually
like roasted them and then they were
[ __ ] delicious oh she was overcooking
the brussels sprouts too yeah okay yeah
yeah it just smells like it makes your
whole house smell like farts when you're
sucking like feet
no farts it smells like [ __ ] sulfur
is what it smells like no she didn't
overcook those my grandmother didn't
overcook them danny rolling ghost faces
canned french style green beans are good
are they i just yeah i kind of feel like
maybe yeah yeah maybe like the green
beans are okay but i do kind of feel
like a lot of canned green vegetables
are not really that good like like lime
juice and stuff yeah bacon yeah well we
cooked everything in bacon grease that
made everything better uh but yeah so um
vegetarianism so that was kind of a big
thing that they promoted like i said it
wasn't
the law you could still eat meat but
they did actually like advocate that you
mostly ate uh vegetables and they were
big advocates of exercise as i said at a
time when i mean now everybody's like
well duh but back then
i kind of feel like people thought it
wasn't really that important it wasn't
really part of everyone's daily routine
i guess
uh so it was kind of a little bit i
don't think it was weird necessarily it
was just that it wasn't all that
mainstream to like be into vegetarianism
and exercising and stuff
um and also he was kind of like
he was very we kind of referred to this
earlier
and this was very much a seventh-day
adventist thing they advocated eating a
bland diet
because they thought that eating
something that was too spicy or sweet or
something like that or that tasted too
good would make you horny essentially
and that was something that they just
could not abide there's a lot of [ __ ]
that they [ __ ] thought was bad they
thought that eating a rich diet would
ruin your teeth
it would cause your teeth to go rotten
fall out
that's not what it was
rich people were eating rich diets
they were also brushing their teeth
poor people did not [ __ ] brush their
teeth
poor people's teeth lasted a lot longer
than rich people's
it's because in that era rich people
were brushing their teeth
with toothpaste made out of powdered
glass
and it would destroy the enamel on their
teeth and their teeth would rot out
didn't anything do the food they had to
do the [ __ ] toothpaste
so there's a lot of misconceptions
about yeah they probably thought they
were cleaning their teeth but it's like
really thick yeah they didn't realize
that there was like enamel on your teeth
and you actually kind of need that yeah
uh so don't like rub it off and they
would say well these poor people their
teeth last their whole lives it's
because of those simple diets they're
eating
no it's because they're not brushing
their teeth with glass they weren't
brushing their teeth at all
it was better not to brush your teeth at
all
than to brush your teeth with what they
were brushing their teeth with in the
1700s well like i said it's just like
back then it was better to drink beer
than water right that doesn't mean that
it's better to drink beer than water now
right but back then it was because of
the sanitation evidently real poor
people did not brush their teeth and
their teeth lasted their whole lives
they weren't eating sugar
they were uh they were not brushing
their teeth with [ __ ] [ __ ] that would
[ __ ] their teeth up
and they were they were eating things
that would just kind of break the plaque
off their teeth you know coarse stuff
and bread
you know so
yeah they did their teeth didn't rot out
funny but true
xanada says i need time to teach me how
to cook my girl can cook but i need to
learn
just dude there's all kinds of people
you can learn from on [ __ ] online
i can't go down there and [ __ ] teach
you how to cook bro
buy my cookbook
zach says well who would have the energy
to get horny when you're probably
suicidal because your life is so boring
maybe so maybe they were onto something
maybe they were on to something
they were just like they the food is so
boring that you're so depressed that you
like can't even like get it up
maybe that's maybe that's what they're
maybe that's what they were thinking
because that's what they advocated they
advocated very they didn't really like
they didn't like spicy food or sweet
food no sugar no nothing no alcohol no
smoking
no caffeine
see i just i i can't get down with this
yeah the thinking of the time though was
to pontificate and then not follow
through we know what they really did
well now according to all kinds of [ __ ]
according to everybody that knew him i
will give him this dr kellogg apparently
did practice what he preached
he did according yeah well yeah i'm sure
he was the only one yeah nobody else did
but nobody else were like yeah i'm
totally doing that i'm certainly not
doing that um and like i said i don't
know if that's true i don't know the
dude that was a long time ago but
apparently he was a vegetarian
apparently he was abstinent like he was
married for 40 odd years and like him
and his wife apparently never had sex i
don't do you actually believe that i
don't i actually believe that but it's
like a very common uh legend about him i
don't know if it's true i mean it's not
impossible it's unlikely i will say that
it's unlikely
but uh yeah so
people of the bygone era lied through
their [ __ ] teeth
yeah xanada says no caffeine no thanks
yeah that's kind of weird
back then i could live without alcohol i
like alcohol don't get me wrong um i
could live without it if somebody said
hey you know you have a problem you
can't drink anymore i just feel like
okay it'd be hard but you know i i could
do it but if somebody said you can't
drink coffee anymore [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that from my studies and in my
experiences in the deep south with the
old southerners of my grandparents age
they lied to their teeth about morality
and sticking to things it was all about
[ __ ] putting out a good [ __ ]
public image kind of like the japanese
they had a public face and a private
face
that's [ __ ] public face [ __ ] they
didn't follow that [ __ ]
that dude didn't follow that he and his
wife had sex that's crazy xander says
anyone who doesn't like coffee to me is
suspect
yeah i mean i could see it it is an
acquired taste i get that so i
understand like if some people don't
like it or oh they like tea better or
whatever i'm not gonna like get too
upset about it but
anybody that doesn't have any vice
or says they don't have any advice the
suspect i'm very suspicious of those
types of people
any of these church-going people [ __ ]
teetotaling and [ __ ] casting
dispersions about people
drinking dispersions
about [ __ ] drinking it's the reason
why they're doing this because they're
drinking because they're drunks yeah
yeah i mean at least like a projection
like i'm a drunk but i admit i'm a drunk
no you're not that much of a drug
constant constant projection
okay yeah whoever [ __ ] screams the
loudest and project the [ __ ]
that's how they are
they can't control their own lives so
they have to control other people's well
because and so they assume that everyone
is like that like them yeah and it's
like oh everyone's as shitty a person as
i am yeah so everybody needs to be like
kept in line i'm like no you need to be
kept in line nobody else has a problem
but you i see it i see it even to this
day on social media people i know
in the [ __ ]
facebook comments
facebook [ __ ]
on there people we know personally
[ __ ]
saying [ __ ] and [ __ ] grandstanding
you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] stop it you're
the biggest hoe here [ __ ] yeah it's
just it's just funny you know what i
mean it's that constant
it's not just church people it's regular
people well the thing about it right now
it's just a certain kind of person
and you know her
you know her well
whatever she's screaming and crying
about it's because that's how she is or
if she starts talking about some girl
how fat that girl's ass is it's because
she wishes she had a booty like that
it's just that same [ __ ] thing
same [ __ ] well i think it it must be
a specific personality type because to
be honest
i'm just the kind of person it has
literally never occurred to me
yeah ever
um to tell other people how they should
live their life yeah
um i mean within reason like if you're
doing some [ __ ] like if you're a serial
killer or you're like going or you're a
mass shooter well obviously because
that's like affecting other people's
lives too thank you but you know what i
mean if you're affecting other people's
lives that's different but if you're
just like doing your own [ __ ] like you
could eat what you want i don't give a
[ __ ] if you're a vegetarian if you're a
vegan it doesn't bother me it doesn't
have anything to do with me i don't care
who the [ __ ] you're sleeping with i
don't care if what the [ __ ] you're
smoking i don't care i don't care um it
doesn't have anything to do with me
you're not hurting anybody um
and i don't really understand i don't i
don't understand people that are so
arrogant that they think that they can
tell other people how to live how to
live that doesn't like i said there's a
caveat because like if your [ __ ] is like
affecting other people then yeah that's
different
but if it's not affecting anybody else
like who you're sleeping with
that does not affect anybody else yeah
yes it does a church person or other
religious person can
wordsmith that into
because you're [ __ ] that [ __ ] it is
just it's the deterioration of society
and because society is deteriorating
it's affecting me so you should be held
accountable because you're [ __ ] that
[ __ ] down and you're not married to her
no that the of course of course you can
wordsmith it
to be anything it what it boils down to
is that there's a certain kind of person
who cannot control their own lives
so they're out of control
their only defense is to try to control
the lives of other people because they
can't control their own or they're
trying to make themselves feel better
feel better by thinking that like oh
well everyone's as [ __ ] up as i am
right and i have this problem how to do
it so obviously everyone else has this
problem also but they don't though yeah
that's how
it's in that projection
imagination it has never occurred
it has never occurred to me
to tell other people
how to live their life when it doesn't
affect me yeah that's why i don't
understand like even minor [ __ ] like you
know how people will get an argument on
the internet it's like i was reading an
article or i don't know why i was
reading this but it's like you know
pancakes versus waffles i'm like look
they're both good yeah you know what i
mean
just trivial [ __ ]
chicago pizza versus new york pizza who
cares they're both good i'm not going to
get in a fight about it eat what you
want i'm not going to get all through
you know people got a all up in my case
because i put ketchup on hot dogs yeah i
gotta laugh at the ketchup on hot dogs
but look you're not eating it but i i
think it's just funny though i don't
you're not eating it yeah so it's like
what the [ __ ] does it have to do with it
yeah no nothing
nothing yeah so i i don't really cheryl
says top is a book cookbook yeah yeah
yeah we have a cookbook it's on it's on
lulu it's on uh amazon as well amazon
what's up
cooking time with 13 o'clock
cooking time and it has cooking
without a g southern classics some of
the shit's family classics the chocolate
eclair recipes from the 1930s from a
[ __ ] from a [ __ ] duncan hines
cookbook i got i wish i could find that
video where we made those though yeah
that was like a few years ago 1930s [ __ ]
they were like this
[ __ ] they were like yeah yeah bigger
than hockey pucks they were like that
and i got how to make some very so good
very simple mexican food
uh and also why not very we got indian
food and then food
there's a little bit of thai food a
little bit of chinese food stuff that we
make elvis favorite dishes stuff that we
make all the time we put all that fool's
gold it's got elvis's fool's gold in
there and i have some stuff that like my
grandma used to make like gooey butter
cake and yeah that kind of stuff like
that kind of stuff is in there stuff
that we make all the time that was like
our yeah kind of thing and basic kitchen
skills are slightly covered in there
from what i remember uh
and uh what else is in there
no i think that book's probably about 25
bucks huh
i think it's 20 is it
i think it's 30. yeah it's hard it's
hard but it's hardcover it's hardback
and it's full color do we have one here
um
yeah but i don't remember where it is
see if it's up there on the very very
top of that
what am i pointing at not that one i'm
pointing at this other one over here see
if it's like very much uh like way up at
the top
xanada says hitler was the biggest tea
totaler vegetarian hated cigarettes and
alcohol meanwhile churchill was
constantly drunk yeah there it is that's
what it looks like kicking cooking time
kicking time yeah it could be that too
it's full color
i'm not that drunk seriously
oh i have to hold it yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't want to stand here
you don't want to stand here yeah we got
all except look there's like some
brazilian recipes that thomas that's the
cream corn that we make every
thanksgiving yeah that's brazilian
creamed corn it's got real cream and
it's so good yeah
it's like there's our sweet and sour
chicken recipe
jenny made it oh
it's pineapple upside down okay like my
grandma used to make yeah
man all kind of [ __ ] oh that's your
strawberry shortcake recipe the only
thing we we didn't do is we didn't do
the down there's metric conversion but
oh no i i think i did i did it on some
of the things well no i did um well i
for sure did like fahrenheit and celsius
right i don't remember if i did metric
though there's like we did indian food
because we make a lot of ingredients so
if you're in europe and you don't know
american food this will [ __ ] i think
i did point you in the right direction
also got cajun stuff in there chili con
carne is mexican food and i think i got
gumbo in there he has gumbo in there i
even have a recipe for we did like a
whole breakfast sandwich section there
yeah that's like yeah yeah man i did
this whole photo i'm proud of myself
yeah [ __ ] book i love doing book
layouts gotta think
senator says yeah look at haystacks
yeah ambrosia
ambrosia salad yeah man you gotta take
lime pie
pumpkin sweet potato pie and pumpkin pie
i didn't put chess pie in there my
grandma used to make that chocolate
eclairs
lemon bundt cake
eggplant parmesan italian foods i've got
about that chicken tandoori butter
chicken
chana masala sag paneer
seriously tom makes the best butter
chicken yeah egg food young i got that
in there yeah different kinds of fried
rice ooh i love egg foo young yeah
i'll leave i even get that at a
restaurant pot stickers and crab rangoon
yeah hell yeah
like i said it's
it doesn't really have any theme it's
just everything it's just stuff that we
made that we made
garnier which is like all over the world
the whole world of tacos we just make
whatever how to make tortillas and corn
tortillas yeah because we do that too
cochinia
is this a brazilian classic
yeah it's like a chicken it's like a
croquette like a croquette yeah yeah
creamy demelo verdi okay that's cream
corn
loma de porco which is [ __ ] pork loin
pumpkin soup i think dr kellogg would
not like our cookbook no no hell no
there's two there's too much meat and
there's too much uh spice
and also we're drunks so hush poppies
how to make [ __ ] uh fried fish tart
how to make tartar sauce see i always i
include corn southern style cornbread
chicken pot pie
so even like uh some
things that you can't get in europe
sometimes i got the recipe on how to
make that too
like certain spice blend because i kind
of feel like it's easy to get [ __ ]
nowadays we were worried about stuff
like if you're making gumbo and you need
like gumbo filet i don't know how easy
that is to get right like in europe like
you can get it here like pretty easy but
yeah i don't know about other uh places
yeah so what santa's saying about hitler
see i don't look i don't have a problem
if people don't want to drink that's
fine if people don't want to smoke like
you know i used to smoke i quit um i'm
not bothered by it uh if other people
want to smoke they can't it doesn't you
know it doesn't bother me
but
i have to say if somebody doesn't have
any vices
like i don't really trust people that
don't have any vices i don't trust
people that don't swear
i don't really trust people that don't
have something you know what i mean
there's got to be something to matter
with you somehow
you know what i mean there's a i don't
know i don't trust people like that
maybe that's unfair i'm not sure
but i kind of feel like you're hiding
something lord haiti says my dad's
obsessed with pumpkin pie if that's in
the cookbook yeah it is yeah that one
and i i also see i included both
if you're a real [ __ ] redneck
hardcore
southern child of the south
you're not supposed to eat pumpkin pie
that's
that's kind of yankee
you're supposed to have sweet potato pie
which is the exact same thing even
though they taste kind of simple they're
real simple gotta
i mean it tastes kind of you have the
spices are almost exactly yeah yeah
pumpkin doesn't have a real distinctive
flavor on its own right
uh the thing that you recognize as
pumpkin spice
is just you know cinnamon it's that
mix of spices which is the pretty much
the same thing that you put in sweet
potato pie so i got them on the same
page
yeah all right now now assad
who [ __ ] uh [ __ ] and saudi [ __ ]
can't get pumpkins so he showed me some
of the squash that he could get that
works too butternut squash works yep
yeah worse too i mean pumpkins just a
squash it's hard to tell before really
so he said he's gonna make one with that
butternut squash
it's not butternut it's the one the big
one is shaped like a damn dick what is
that butternut no i thought they were
all shaped like no it's no it's it's
long it's like kind of like i thought
that was a butter that's a better
question
i think so i think a butternut squash
was a little bit shorter but yeah yeah
i'm not saying i have to remember this
kind of [ __ ] right now
i'm pretty sure that's butternut squash
though well the thing about it though is
that like i said pumpkin i think that
people like think that pumpkin actually
is a flavor because everything's pumpkin
spice everything but pumpkin spice
is just just squash
yeah it's just a squash so if you just
put it in bread or something like that
by itself it's not going to taste like
anything it doesn't really taste like
much of anything the reason why pumpkin
is used a lot
is because a single pumpkin can get
[ __ ] big which means the yield is
really good
yeah we've talked about that before you
get a [ __ ] ton of food
two big pumpkins only cost maybe ten
bucks each will yield not even they were
six bucks each
six bucks each i can put a big [ __ ]
bucket i can redo cook it and redo and
then blend it
and make an entire
[ __ ] huge five gallon bucket
of blended pumpkin meat
and with that you can do so much you can
make pumpkin curry with it you can make
pumpkin bread
you can make
pumpkin pie muffins cookies muffins
cookies yeah you can do anything with
soup yeah pumpkin soup
that pumpkin curry was good it was
pumpkin chicken but like i said it's you
know it it doesn't have a great deal of
flavor on its own
you just have to like it's the spices
yeah it's the spices it's the cinnamon
you can lick like you know you can put
nuts in it like pecans or something like
that more just an energy source at a
texture yeah
i mean i'm a big fan of pumpkin yeah but
you it's a good vegetable you need to
add stuff to it like to make it taste
like something
you can make it anything you can make it
sweeter savory it's neutral
so you can make it spicy